can exist what does that mean like you
know like my daughter these toys lol
shop that were they they show videos of
them are the slime videos of do like
YouTube and those kind of things I just
think that there is a certain level of
like just ignore it if you don't like it
well it's not your thing the lawsuit
thing totally that's out of this context
a little bit there's a big difference
between something that you might find
gross and something that changes culture
so I think what they're worried about is
do you mind when Jim Acosta did that he
went to that Trump rally and they went
crazy on him do you remember that [ __ ] I
don't know is a recent thing couple
weeks ago he's a CNN anchor who is
reasonably self righteous but he's in a
difficult situation he has to challenge
the President of the United States who
is also a famous celebrity billionaire
guy was his name on buildings I mean
this literally is rosebud this is this
is the tale of Citizen Kane I mean this
is someone with ungodly power and
influence and this Jim I'm not standing
up for Jim Acosta I'm just gonna say
just put yourself in that guy's position
what a crazy spot you're yelling out
questions at the president knighted
States who also happens to be Donald
Trump you think like you're on acid
you should the world the world has gone
into a vortex of crazy and you're the
guy by some [ __ ] freak of chance
whether you're Jim Acosta or Don Lemon
or or fill in the blank everyone you're
one of those [ __ ] people hold this
[ __ ] it was the weed thought oh [ __ ] I
got to turn that off if you're one of
those [ __ ] people and that's your job
and we expect them to handle that that's
probably like being Beyonce and the rock
on steroids in a negative way it
wouldn't be those two because those are
like very beloved celebrities like very
few people are as beloved as the rock or
Beyonce
they're pretty much universally beloved
like uniquely so they're so loved and so
deserving of that love but if you're a
guy like who's like a real netic Takashi
six nine that kid like you imagine the
hate that guy gets all day now imagine
what is that he said six he's a rapper